[Music]
welcome back to curious archive
this video is the second half of my
two-part series on the biology of
horizon zero dawn
in the most extreme biomes of this world
of machines ill-tempered titans
skilled survivalists and genuine terrors
still await discovery like the animals
braving the harshest regions of our
current age these machines have had to
get creative to endure the hazards of
the elements
the environments are perilous in the
machines that live here even more so but
sometimes discovery requires certain
risks
and with mysterious robots that aren't
part of the ecosystem awakening in the
darkest corners of the land who knows
what final secrets are buried beneath
the ground
so join me on the last section of our
documentary style journey as we conclude
our expedition across the uncharted
regions
in the dense jungles of the far south a
fearsome storm batters the trees
typically i'd wait until such weather
passes but right now time is of the
essence for one of the rarest and most
spectacular machines of all has been
spotted here
a huge shadow passes overhead
above my position is the single
mightiest machine of all the skies
a storm bird
they're huge with wing beats so powerful
they echo like thunderclaps the storm
bird is not afraid of the hurricane
raging around them for this machine is
the storm
and unfortunately for me these solitary
beings are highly territorial soaring
close to the ground the storm bird
crackles with electrical discharge
at the heart of this machine is what
appears to be an electric field
generator and this storm bird is about
to give me a zap
my camera takes the brunt of the blast
this is why you always bring extra
recording equipment documenting a storm
bird in the middle of a storm turns out
to be an inadvisable idea
eventually however the storm calms down
and after losing sight of me the
stormbird has also mellowed out in the
warm light of dawn it is easier to
appreciate the majesty of this ruler of
the skies across the land there are no
machines quite like them and our
sighting is a promising start to the
expedition
without the gloom of the storm the true
beauty of this jungle emerges with just
the right amount of sunlight and
nutrients this tropical band of forest
is a paradise yet even the luscious
gardens have their thorns
a chill runs down the back of my neck a
shimmer seems to ripple in the morning
light
i don't think i'm alone
something invisible is moving through
the underbrush
for a brief moment the camouflage
flickers
and the stealthy machine becomes
perceptible
this is a stalker a nimble hunter whose
sinewy frame seems designed in every way
for ambush attacks their demeanor
mirrors that of a large feline predator
with each measured step hiding the
incredible speed they're truly capable
of and the stalker can take their
ambushes to another level through the
use of optical camouflage they can
project the terrain behind them onto
their bodies this form of invisibility
is almost perfect with only a slight
bend in the light suggesting the
stalkers outline
and as the stalker moves they leave
behind small proximity mines that will
detonate if i get too close
alerting the stalker to my presence
trying to keep one eye where i'm
stepping and one eye on the underbrush
is harrowing yet i have discovered a
single weakness in order to take in
light the stalker's optical sensors must
remain visible if i keep watch for these
floating dots i should be able to
anticipate attacks
yet knowing an attack is coming is one
thing surviving an attack is another one
stalker has evidently decided they've
waited enough and goes on the offensive
uncloaking they take a hurried swipe at
my head
a close call
every part of the stalker is built for
combat from the metal claws and teeth of
their front to the stinger-like blade at
the end of their tail i doubt this is a
fight i can win
yet just as quickly as the stalker
appears they vanish
disappearing once more to wait for their
next opportunity i'm not keen on another
surprise attack and decide to continue
my expedition in a region with a thinner
underbrush
i travel to the north a region where
very little vegetation grows
here a vast stone quarry stretches along
the length of a canyon this colossal
excavation project appears long
abandoned yet somehow the site still
feels occupied a terrible rumbling
echoes through the quarry
something is moving under the surface of
the rock
for a brief moment a gigantic machine
breaches from the sand like a surfacing
whale stumbling backwards i witnessed
the metal goliath rise up and clamp
their jaws where i had just been
standing
before diving once again
that was a rock breaker one of the
largest known machines these agents of
destruction can shred through any
material like a sentient excavation
drill they use this ability to swim
under the earth's crust as a fish moves
through water when they detect a sound
they move shark-like to the source of
the noise and attack the unlucky target
from below if a target is difficult to
apprehend rock breakers will briefly
surface
giving us a chance to look more closely
at their anatomy while they might
function like a fish rock breakers
possess powerful limbs that resemble an
excavator shovel tunneling animals like
badgers or moles have similar digging
mitts that they use to create their
burrows
the most prominent tunneling tool of the
rock breaker though is their massive
mouth composed of an enormous roller
cone drill bit with this feature a rock
breaker can swallow vast quantities of
raw material each day yet what goes down
must come up and the rock breaker needs
to regularly regurgitate processed
stones into the air which rain down upon
the surface
with a rock breaker on the loose this
quarry is as perilous as it gets
time to tiptoe away to our next location
in the western desert i spot a herd of
antelope-like creatures racing over the
dunes these are lance horns and while i
only catch a glimpse of them they look
majestic yet they are clearly in a hurry
and i soon find out why out of nowhere a
heavy sandstorm sweeps over the western
reaches
stumbling through the storm i find
various familiar machines are also
struggling to press on against the
howling winds all any of us can do is
keep moving and hope the storm dies down
but there is something in this cloud
more dangerous than the elements
stalking within the sandstorm is a
terror from a lost age
moving on four scorpion-like legs this
machine isn't like the others i've seen
not a part of the larger machine
ecosystem they possess no behavior
beyond unreasoning hostility
yet how did such a machine come to be
this stretch of desert called the rust
watch is scattered with mysterious ruins
it seems a battle was waged here long
ago with many dormant machines of war
now rusting away in the sand
perhaps this corruptor is the last one
still functioning a thoughtless agent of
war from a conflict that ended a
millennia ago
in any case i have a more current
problem the corrupter has spotted me yet
to my surprise before the corrupter can
strike other machines descend upon it
from all directions unleashing every
attack in their arsenal like immune
system cells descending upon an
infection the other machines seem to
instinctually see the corrupter as a
threat to the ecosystem it's a
surprising turn but not one i wish to
dwell on as the ensuing chaos has given
me the perfect opportunity to make a
hasty exit yet while i leave the rust
watch i can't help but wonder if there
are other long lost machines hidden away
in the margins of this world
with the western desert and southern
jungle now charted the greatest frontier
of all still remains far to the north
the frozen wilds in immense mountainous
region beckoned with the promise of
untouched wilderness temperatures drop
low in the forests and mountains of
these wilds with the wind carrying cold
drafts of snow between the trees it's a
good thing i've come with layers yet
some denizens of this mountainous forest
don't have to bundle up rushing ahead of
me is a herd of remarkable machines
chargers
these swift-footed beings are the
champions of the freezing alpine slopes
and are comfortable on inclines most
creatures wouldn't dare to climb
in behavior and general appearance
chargers are perhaps most similar to
mountain goats
there are organic mountain goats present
in this region in a rare instance of
machines alongside the animal whose role
they fill as herbivorous machines
chargers spend much of their time
seeking out patches of vegetation
unlike some herbivores though chargers
have an aggressive side when i step too
close the machines rush towards me
kicking wildly to scare me off i
certainly now understand why these
animals are called chargers it's a
lesson i'll be sure to remember better
leave these slopes to the chargers
moving to the valley below i discover a
landscape of surreal prismatic hot
springs these natural springs exist in
the modern day and tells me this is a
region we would know as yellowstone
national park the bright vivid colors in
the spring are the result of microbial
mats around the edges of the
mineral-rich water
and dropping at the water's edge is a
herd of bellowing giants these huge
stocky machines are known as tramplers
with their massive head neck and chest
tramplers look like no force on earth
could knock them down with so much bulk
they seem to be less bothered by the
falling temperatures than i am like the
bison of north america tramplers are
highly resistant to the wind and snow
and for any non-elemental challenges a
pair of huge horn-like structures keep
the tramplers prepared for anything
tramplers also use these horns to dig up
rock and soil they work tirelessly
stopping only to change location to
another spot but for what purpose soil
analysis suggests that tramplers are in
fact purifying the toxin-laden soil of
this land
they filter the material they dig up
through a processing unit on their
underside which glows with heat from its
arduous task
with each region the tramplers pass
through the immediate ecosystem becomes
a little healthier but tramplers aren't
always peaceful highly territorial these
bulls will charge interlopers with
unpredictable speed
if pushed tramplers will even use their
processing units to set the environment
ablaze scorching the land they typically
protect
wanting to avoid such an outcome i stay
out of range of the herd's optical
sensors and watch them pass
on cresting the next hill i witness a
tall neck trudging through the snow it's
surprising to see one this far north but
it seems not even the cold can slow
these beings down or the trees for that
matter which this tallneck seems to take
little notice of i find it is comforting
to see a familiar machine in such an
unfamiliar land yet just ahead looms a
machine that is distinctly unfamiliar
these are control towers and unlike all
other types of machines they look
botanical rather than zoological to my
astonishment the strange machine then
releases a cloud of spiraling drones
into the air
that burst with bizarre purple energy as
it turns out control towers act as the
unofficial hearts of the synthetic
ecosystem with their drones helping to
repair nearby machines their bizarre
appearance is the result of this
peculiar sessile lifestyle why bother
with locomotion when your legion of
loyal drones can go anywhere you can't
while the undulating movements of these
towers subtly resemble the motion of
coral control towers have no clear
natural analogs yet in repairing damaged
machines the importance of their role in
the continued health of the ecosystem
cannot be overstated and with such a
vital occupation control towers are
fiercely defended by the machines they
repair
on that note i think i've gotten close
enough already
to the north the snowfall has become
heavier like the sandstorm in the
western desert a blizzard descends over
this region in a matter of minutes even
with my layers of protection i'll need
to find shelter if i am to survive this
onslaught in the distance i spot a cave
illuminated with the artificial lights
of the hunter-gatherer communities who
occupy this region perhaps refuge awaits
inside
no such luck
from the cave emerges a fiery machine
this is a scorcher and they have taken
over this cave from its previous
occupants their tall pointed ears give
them a vulpine appearance although
scorchers seem far less skittish i
suspect the snow is now the least of my
worries
waiting for an attack i watch the
scorcher crouch down then rock it
forwards leaving a blazing trail a near
hit
despite living in a cold environment the
scorcher is an agent of the inferno
creating devastating if somewhat
inaccurate walls of fire i might be cold
but this is no way to warm up
time to find a different shelter
stumbling through the storm i happen at
last upon a snow-covered ruin the
structure has seen better days but i'll
have to take my chances
the inside is thankfully much warmer but
what is this a ruin of
a collection of forgotten animal statues
in the corner gives me a clue i'm
standing in the ruins of the yellowstone
national park visitor center and these
statues are sadly the last record of
their respective species once this
building falls these animals will be
lost to time
through a crack in the wall i noticed
the snow outside has calmed down
the time has come to complete the final
leg of my journey
at the foot of the mountains rises a
fortress like ruin this was once a
hydroelectric dam through which vast
quantities of water still flow and
stalking the base of this dam is one of
the most dangerous machines of the
frozen wilds a frost claw
like polar bears frost claws have
muscular builds and are practically
immune to the cold
indeed frost claws are the champions of
the ice
using a chemical similar to liquid
nitrogen frost claws can create sharp
spikes of frozen coolant transforming
the surrounding area into a forest of
jagged ice
much of the dam is now covered with
these glacial stalagmites
and this frost claw is not alone a fire
claw has also made their home on this
dam
this infernal machine is even larger
than their icy cousin and they are known
to be even more aggressive the frost
claws opposite fire claws wield flames
much like scorchers frost and fire claws
might not seem like they'd get along but
surprisingly these two seem to tolerate
each other with both a frost claw and a
fire claw at this site close
documentation is a serious risk
fortunately the dam's ruins provide
reliable cover
all i have to do is find a space too
narrow for the machines to fit through
and stay hidden until the coast is clear
at the very edge of the world the final
stop on our journey is a bleak graveyard
like the wreckage of the rust watch this
seems to have been the site of a great
battle yet who or what were the ancient
humans fighting against when
civilization fell
tromping through the snow is a metal
monster unlike any seen before this
ancient horror is a deathbringer the
last machine standing in this grim
cemetery like the smaller corruptor i
encountered in the sands the
deathbringer has no resemblance to any
fauna and is simply a unit of
destruction many of its weapon systems
are no longer functioning but it seethes
with blind hate nonetheless
perhaps it was rogue units like this one
that were the cause of humanity's
collapse or perhaps the deathbringers
were aided by something much bigger
throughout my travels i've witnessed
many immense metal tentacles snaking
over the mountains these machines known
simply as metal devils have been in the
back of my mind this entire voyage
no still functioning units of this
machine are known to exist but their
proximity to ruined battlefields raised
suspicion i suspect these machines were
responsible for the doom of the previous
ecosystem and the animal machines that
populate this land were built to return
the world to a habitable state
in time these ruins will hopefully be
forgotten
and earth will become the planet it once
was
warming up in the temperate safety of
the embrace i consider all i've seen in
this strange future while a quiet
sadness permeates throughout the ruins
of this world the interconnected
machines that populate the land have
given the planet new life so to speak
i've heard rumors of a vastly different
ecosystem of machines in a region known
as the forbidden west and if passage to
that location is ever possible perhaps
someday i'll chart it as well but for
now the time has come to return home
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
you